do you regret putting the tattoo on your
face no way you don't you love it cuz I
thought it was the most severe thing was
almost like you were angry at yourself
this is what this was me playing Pop
psychologist I was like Mike's just
[__] pissed off and he just wants to
claim his own body in a way like in the
most severe way like like say [__] it
man this I'm going that's interesting
that you had that CU I felt like I was
on my whole life right and I think this
was your way of trying to own your own
body it's not that way but it is that
way why did you do it because I thought
it was an awesome tattoo and I wanted it
yeah well yeah and I did it because I
knew people would say that why did you
do that why did you that I it's totally
I it's totally abstract from the average
thinking person of course you know for
years most tattoo artists would never
tattoo a guy's face a lot of them will
not do it well my artist wouldn't tattoo
my face because my first idea was in
this um Maui signature it was a bunch of
hearts and stuff and he said I'm not
going to do that why he just don't want
to have his work he thought it was that
wasn't fitting for me and so he said I
need he said if you do anything you need
to be a war he said you're a warrior you
need to have a warrior signal um
signature in your facei right and so you
said okay put it on me no I said that's
fine one he said come back in a couple
of days and I'll call you and we'll look
over some tribal are you glad he did
that yeah I'm so happy he did right it's
funny that he says that he spent days
before he got that because everybody
assumed it was a spontaneous no no when
you have a truly professional tattoo
artist he's not g to put anything on
your face with his signature on it he's
not gonna do it not gonna do it because
it's one of the most famous tattoos in
the world right yeah Ian he's just not
going to but he didn't look at it he
didn't look at it that because Mike
tyton he never looked at Mike tyton
going have my tattoo cuz I wanted heart
he could have just put heart to in my
face he said I'm not doing that you have
to go somewhere else you don't in but I
respect that and so we look for a good
tattoo